[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen Freitagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen alles Wichtige vom
Sport von Norbert König guten Abend
schauen wir auf unsere Themen
neue Aufgabe für ein Oldie auch
zahlreiche Leopard 1 Panzer sollen rund
erneuert an die Ukraine geliefert werden
Einladung unter Vorbehalt die EU
verspricht der Ukraine Hilfe aber kein
schnellen Beitritt zur Union
mit Hightech in die Vergangenheit wie
künstliche Intelligenz das Puzzle
uralter Keilschriften zusammensetzt
[Musik]
neben den Leopard 2 soll die Ukraine aus
Deutschland jetzt auch die Leopard 1
Panzer bekommen so gab die
Bundesregierung heute für eine Lieferung
grünes Licht die Leopard 1 sind deutlich
älter als die Leopard 2 von 1965 bis
Mitte der 80er Jahre wurden 4.700 Stück
produziert die Bundeswehr hat ihre
Exemplare bereits vor 20 Jahren
ausgemustert von der Firma Rheinmetall
heißt es sie könne 88 Panzer dieses Typs
bereitstellen und auch die Flensburger
fahrzeugbaugesellschaft hat noch
Bestände dort ist die Rede von etwa 100
Leopard eins Thomas Reichert und Lena
sünderbruch
seit Monaten drängt die Ukraine darauf
die von der Bundeswehr vor Jahren
ausgemusterten Leopard 1 Panzer zu
bekommen rund 100 davon stehen in einer
Halle der Rüstungsfirma FFG in Flensburg
schon Mitte letzten Jahres hat die FFG
in Berlin den Antrag auf
Ausfuhrgenehmigung in die Ukraine
gestellt heute gibt der
Regierungssprecher bekannt die Leopard 1
können und dürfen geliefert werden kann
ich bestätigen dass es eine Auswirkung
dass eine Ausfuhr Genehmigung erteilt
worden ist viel mehr möchte ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht sagen das wird
sich dann in den nächsten Tagen und
Wochen noch konkretisieren womöglich die
ersten Leopard eins der FFG könnten in
etwa drei Monaten geliefert werden
später dann mehr weitere 88 Leopard 1
hat rein Metall deren Wiederherstellung
dauert bis Anfang nächsten Jahres
erklärte das Unternehmen vor ein paar
Wochen der Leopard ein sehr ungefähr
vergleichbar mit vielen Panzern die
Russland Einsätze und er sei ein großes
Stückzahl verfügbar von daher soll ich
mal ist besser als wenn wir 14
Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 schicken da das
letztendlich auch mit Blick auf die
Verluste der Ukraine an Mengenproblem
werden wird Leopard 1 wurden in viele
Länder verkauft dort soll nun auch
Munition eingekauft werden offenbar gibt
es noch genug davon der Vizekanzler
verspricht bei einer fabrikbesichtigung
in Schweden
wir werden wenn die Genehmigung richtig
vorliegt noch mal alle Fragen
beantworten aber in der Bundesliga Part
1 Panzer die aus der Industrie kommen
jedenfall
den Weg frei gemacht hatte wohl die
Entscheidung für die Lieferung von
modernen Leopard 2 Panzern letzte Woche
die alten Leopard 1 sollen zusätzlich zu
den bereits angekündigten zwei
Panzerbataillonen geliefert werden
in Kiew ist unsere Reporterin Katrin
Eigendorf Katrin wie reagiert die
Ukraine darauf dass sie jetzt auch
Leopard 1 Panzer bekommt
ja man zeigt sich hier ziemlich erfreut
darüber wenn es auch einige kritische
Stimmen gibt die sagen das kommen zu
spät die Entscheidung ich hatte heute
die Gelegenheit mit dem Chef des
nationalen Sicherheitsrates Danilov über
das Thema zu sprechen und der sagte es
ist ganz wichtig dass jetzt so viel wie
möglich an Technik zur Verfügung
gestellt wird eben das auch alte Technik
einen Unterschied machen kann und er hat
das sehr begrüßt er sagt die Ukraine
befindet sich im Moment in einer äußerst
schwierigen Situation sieht sich eine
Offensive der russischen Seite jetzt im
Frühjahr entgegen und da könnte das auch
einen Unterschied machen deswegen es
wird hier von vor allem von Militär und
Sicherheitskreisen sehr sehr positiv
aufgenommen das einzige Problem was ich
hier jetzt noch stellt wird genügend
Munition zur Verfügung gestellt sein und
die Frage sind die Soldaten dafür
ausgebildet aber das sind Probleme sagt
er die sich sicherlich lösen lassen
werden aus der ukrainischen Hauptstadt
gar keinen Eigendorf danke schön
und in Kiel fand heute auch eine
eu-ukraine-gipfel statt die Spitzen der
Europäischen Union stellten sich dabei
noch mal symbolisch an die Seite des
angegriffenen Landes ganz konkret
dagegen es soll neue Sanktionen gegen
Russland geben die EU will eine
Preisobergrenze für russische
diesel-exporte durchsetzen ein baldiger
EU-Beitritt der Ukraine scheint jedoch
unrealistisch über den Gipfel berichtet
Isabel Schäfers Ursula von der Leyen hat
ein Geschenk mitgebracht 35 Millionen
energieeffiziente LED-Lampen damit
sollen die Ukrainer Strom einsparen und
so dem russischen energiekrieg begegnen
so die Idee ein greifbares Mitbringsel
ganz anders als das worum es beim
eu-ukraine Gipfel heute vor allem geht
den EU-Beitritt der Ukraine
wir haben uns schon gut darauf
vorbereitet und erwarten jetzt dass die
EU-Kommission und die Mitgliedstaaten
bald eine Entscheidung treffen das Ziel
ist mit den Beitrittsverhandlungen noch
in diesem Jahr zu beginnen
ein ambitioniertes Ziel dennoch lassen
auch die EU-Spitzen keinen Zweifel sie
unterstützen die Bestrebungen der
Ukraine
wir lassen uns vom Kreml nicht
einschüchtern denn die Ukraine und die
EU sind eine Familie und die Zukunft der
Ukraine liegt in der Europäischen Union
doch der Weg zum Beitritt ist lang viele
Reformen sind nötig sowie die
Einstimmigkeit aller EU-Mitgliedstaaten
beste big im Herbst gibt es den großen
erweiterungsbericht für alle Länder die
der Europäischen Union beitreten wollen
und da müssen dann Daten und Fakten und
Ergebnisse eingebracht werden um zu
zeigen wie gut die Fortschritte vor Ort
tatsächlich waren
heute überwiegen die warmen Worte die
Hoffnung machen sollen aber konkrete
Zusagen gibt es keinen
ein mutmaßlicher chinesischer
spionageballon der über den
US-Bundesstaat Montana fliegt was
skurril klingt hat Konsequenzen so hat
us-ausminister blinken deshalb jetzt
eine für dieses Wochenende geplante
Reise nach Peking abgesagt China
bedauert ein unbeabsichtigtes Eindringen
des Balance in den US-Luftraum eine
weitere Belastung für die Beziehung
zwischen China und den USA Claudia Bates
was vom Boden aus nur als kleiner Punkt
am Himmel sichtbar ist versetzt die USA
in Unruhe Kampfjets standen bereit denn
für die US-Regierung ist klar dies ist
ein chinesischer spionageballon Experten
schätzen ihn auf eine Größe von drei
buslingen
der Ballon fliegt weiter über die USA
nach unserer Einschätzung stellt er
momentan keine Gefahr da militärisch
oder für Menschen wir beobachten ihn
weiter und wegen unsere Optionen ab
das chinesische Interesse könnte der
malmsram Air Force Base in Montana
gelten wo auch Atomwaffen Lagern moderne
spionageballons fliegen in einer Höhe
von rund 30 Kilometern sie sind billiger
als Satelliten und können länger über
einer Stelle verharren China sagt der
Ballon diene der zivilen Forschung und
sei vom Kurs abgekommen nach
us-erkenntnissen stimmt das nicht
es zeigt einfach dass das Verhältnis mit
China sehr angespannt bleibt es ist
ziemlich klar China Präsident Chi ist
deutlich aggressiver geworden
Außenminister blinken wollte in wenigen
Stunden aufbrechen zu einer geplanten
Reise nach China den Besuch hat er
verschoben und den amtierenden
chinesischen Botschafter einbestellt
die Reaktion waren vorhersehbar die
politische Konkurrenz wett hat gegen die
Doppelrolle von Nancy Feser denn die
Hessen-SPD hat heute auch formal
beschlossen dass sie Spitzenkandidatin
bei der Landtagswahl im Herbst wird
trotzdem will Feser
bundesinnenministerin bleiben und auch
nur nach Wiesbaden wechseln wenn sie
Ministerpräsidentin wird Klaus Brodbeck
über eine Kandidatin im Meinungsstreit
zwei hier sind bereits
ministerpräsidentinnen nennt sie Feser
will das in Hessen nun werden bis zur
Wahl bleibt sie bundesinnenministerin
bei einer Niederlage wohl auch danach
die Landespartei steht geschlossen
hinterher
ich kann erfreulich sagen dass mich die
Gremien der hessischen SPD gerade
einstimmig zur
Spitzenkandidatin für die nächste
Landtagswahl am 8 Oktober diesen Jahres
gewählt haben der Justizminister von der
FDP unterstützt Faeser ohne Menschen die
sich zur Wahl stellen gibt es keine
Auswahl und keine Demokratie daher
sollte man das nicht kritisieren der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Grünen hingegenmahnt die Führung des
Bundesinnenministeriums ist kein
Teilzeitjob gerade nicht in diesen
Zeiten kritik kommt von der Opposition
das bundesinnenministerin wird sie
versuchen den Wahlkampf zu beeinflussen
durch Themen die auf Bundesebene
gespielt werden und das aber ein
Konkurrenz zum Beispiel auch zu den
Regierungsparteien glaube das insgesamt
Bundespolitik dadurch Schaden nehmen
wird es zeigt auch dass sie die
Interessen ihrer eigenen Person ganz
offensichtlich höher bewertet als die
Interessen des Landes indem sie einen
Wahlkampf mit Netz und doppelten Boden
machen möchte ja das muss im Endeffekt
der Wähler entscheiden ich denke
jetzt sowas nicht gut weil man natürlich
damit eigentlich zeigt dass man mehr auf
Posten schaut als auf Inhalte fäße
versichert sie Spiele auf Sieg
würde bedeuten Wiesbaden statt Berlin
wenn es denn so kommt
und 100 Tage ist die postfaschistische
Ministerpräsidentin Italiens Georgia
Melone jetzt im Amt heute ist sie zum
Antrittsbesuch bei Kanzler Scholz bei
den Gesprächen geht es vor allem auch um
den Ukraine Krieg und den Umgang mit
gepflüchteten letzteres ist Thema eines
eu-sondergipfels kommende Woche über das
Treffen Scholz Meloni berichtet Britta
Spiekermann ihr Antrittsbesuch kommt
reichlich spät schließlich ist Italiens
Ministerpräsidentin schon drei Monate im
Amt erst jetzt das Kanzleramt ja es hat
den ganzen Nachmittag geregnet sagt Olaf
Scholz kurz klappt es auf Empfang mit
militärischen Ehren soziale Demokratie
trifft auf Italiens Post faschistin
zuletzt gab sich Meloni betont gemäßigt
kritisch beugt von Berlin gemeinsam
stehen Mann an der Seite der Ukraine bei
der Migrationspolitik bleibt die
Hardlinerin überraschend zurückhaltend
wir haben auch ein Sicherheitsproblem
mit Einwanderung und ich denke wir sind
heute alle aufgerufen Verantwortung zu
zeigen
im Gegenzug finde ich aber und das ist
glaube ich wichtig muss das legale Wege
geben um in die Europäische Union
einzuwandern denn wir brauchen ohnehin
Zuwanderung nach Europa im Wahlkampf
mobilisierte Meloni mit einem
anti-europäischen einem
antimigrationskurs für Europa sei der
Spaß nun vorbei so Meloni und ihre
rechtsradikale Partei fratelli Italia
das sorgt bis heute für großes
Misstrauen sie ist postfaschistin ihre
Partei hat sich nicht historisch von
Mussolini abgenabelt und wir werden
jetzt ganz genau gucken ob sie sich an
die demokratischen Spielregeln hält
vergangene Nacht wieder sterben Menschen
vor der Küste Italiens die Regierung in
Rom blockiert zunehmend die zivile
sinotrettung viele Hilfsorganisationen
fahren unter deutscher Flagge Georgia
gibt sich auf der Pressekonferenz
gefällig demokratisch
bleibt die Sorge ist nicht doch die
Wölfin im Schafspelz
auch in Deutschland suchen Menschen
Schutz vor Krieg und Gewalt gerade im
vergangenen Jahr besonders viele
rund
244.000 Asylanträge wurden gestellt vor
allem von Menschen aus Syrien und
Afghanistan hinzu kommen diejenigen die
aus der Ukraine geflüchtet sind über
eine Million waren das bis Ende 2022 sie
müssen keinen Asylantrag stellen das
Problem für viele Kommunen es fehlt an
Wohnraum zu seiner Santina
dieses Zeltlager im hessischen Bensheim
war 2015 wegen der großen
Flüchtlingswelle errichtet worden und
musste im letzten März reaktiviert
werden untergebracht sind hier rund 800
geflüchtete vor allem Männer aus
Afghanistan Irak und der Türkei der
Frust bei vielen ist groß
warum werden wir nicht von hier
weggebracht viele haben mittlerweile
psychische Probleme
seit zwei Monaten sind wir hier unser
Baby hat seit langem Fieber und nichts
passiert wir werden sehr schlecht
versorgt
im letzten Jahr wurden allein dem Kreis
Bergstraße rund 4.000 geflüchtete
zugewiesen für viele Kommunen sind es
viel zu viele um sie ordentlich
unterzubringen Menschen aus 2015 wohnen
zum Teil noch in den
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften und zum
zweiten brauchen wir Ressourcen um zu
integrieren und das macht nur Sinn mit
denen bei denen wir davon ausgehen
können dass sie auch dauerhaft hier
bleiben
Auswahl findet nicht statt das in
Bensheim Menschen mit guten und
schlechten bleibeperspektiven
Zusammenleben auch das sorgt für
Konflikte vor zwei Wochen gab es eine
Schlägereien die dutzende Personen
verwickelt waren die ukrainischen
geflüchteten wurden mittlerweile in
einer Halle im Nachbarort verlegt die
Menschen die zu uns zurecht kommen
müssen wir integrieren und das gelingt
im Augenblick aufgrund der
Gesamtsituation und der Person zahlt uns
zugewiesen wird vor Ort nicht mehr die
Not vieler Kommunen geht vor allem zu
Lasten der geflüchteten viele sitzen
Monate lang in Unterkünften wie in
Bensheim fest ohne Perspektive
türkisch jetzt ist es amtlich das Robert
Koch-Institut hat das Coronavirus auf
seiner Risiko Skala herabgestuft von
hoch auf moderat es gebe zwar weiter
viele Infektionen aber weniger schwere
Krankheitsverläufe und es drohe keine
Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems mehr
nach einem schrecklichen güterzugunglück
gestern Abend in Recklinghausen sind
noch viele Fragen offen wie konnte es
passieren dass zwei Kinder vom Zug
erfasst worden sind ein zehnjähriger
Junge starb einen 9-jähriger wurde
schwer verletzt
drohnenaufnahmen von der Unglücksstelle
sollen bei den Ermittlungen helfen der
bahnabschnitt war bis zum Vormittag
gesperrt
nach dem Chaos und den zahlreichen
Pannen bei der letzten
Abgeordnetenhauswahl in Berlin vor knapp
eineinhalb Jahren muss jetzt ja am 12
februar erneut abgestimmt werden nach
dem aktuellen ZDF Politbarometer extra
liegt die CDU vor der SPD und den Grünen
über den Wahlkampf berichtet Stefan
Merseburger
spannende ist der Kampf ums Rote Rathaus
die noch Regierende Bürgermeisterin
Franziska Giffey und ihre SPD sind zur
Zeit nicht stärkste Kraft Kai Wikinger
CDU liegt vorne laut ZDF Politbarometer
extra kommt die SPD auf 21 die CDU aber
auf
24%, die Grünen liegen bei 18 die Linken
bei 11%, die AFD bekäme 10 die FDP 6%
die Berliner sind mit der Arbeit aller
Parteien unzufrieden weder Regierung
noch Oppositionen bekommen gute Werte
nur die SPD liegt knapp im positiven
Bereich dafür dass sie die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin stellt ein eher
bescheidenes Ergebnis die rot-grün-rote
Koalition verliert ein Zustimmung könnte
aber im Amt bleiben wichtigstes Thema
für die Berliner wohnen und Mieten wie
schon bei der letzten Wahl die
bekanntlich im Fiasko endete und dieses
Mal
ich denke mal es wird wieder alles
schief gehen also es klappt alles und
ich habe eine Wette laufen ich denke
Berlin weiß dass wenn Sie das jetzt
nicht schaffen der Ruf endgültig
ruiniert ist junge Menschen werden zum
Wahlhelfer geschult außerdem so der
Wahlleiter gibt es dieses Mal mehr
Wahlzettel mehr Kabinen und mehr Urnen
Wahlhelfer bekommen statt 60 jetzt 240 €
Aufwandsentschädigung doch das ist nicht
der einzige Antrieb das ist aber auch
bei vielen Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit
denen ich spreche die Motivation wir
wollen zeigen dass Berlin Wahlen kann
und das finde ich geht genau in die
richtige Richtung es wurde keine Aufwand
gescheut Klarheit auch politisch gibt es
am 12 Februar
als sie Menschen begannen ihre Mythen
und hellen Geschichten aufzuschreiben
taten sie das in Keilschrift auf solchen
Tontafeln in Babylon und anderswo
zwischen Euphrat und Tigris diese Tafeln
sind ein Schatz des Wissens über die
Anfänge der Zivilisation das Problem sie
sind zerbrechlich und viele nur noch
Fragmente in München versuchen
Forscherinnen und Forscher jetzt mit
Hilfe von künstlicher Intelligenz
zusammenzufügen was zusammengehört
Christoph Wiesel hat sich das angeschaut
es gleicht einem schier unlösbaren
Puzzle einige der ältesten Dichtungen
der Menschheitsgeschichte verteilt über
Bruchstücke aus Ton sie wieder zu einem
lesbaren Text zusammenzuführen für
Generationen von Forschern ein
ernüchtern des Unterfangen an der Uni
München soll künstliche Intelligenz
diesen Prozess revolutionieren
wollte hätte man mindestens 20 30 Jahre
gedauert jetzt kann man es kann man ihn
wirklich in Sekunden
das Herzstück des Projekts und seine
Kollegen fünf Jahre gearbeitet haben ein
speziell trainierter Algorithmus er
nutzt das viele der babylonischen Texte
mehrfach aufgeschrieben wurden und es so
Passagen gibt die auf mehreren
Bruchstücken auftauchen
zu finden und dann sein
gehört hier und das andere und so weiter
dadurch kann Zeile für Zeile
zurückgewonnen werden heute hat das
Forscherteam eine ganze Reihe bisher
unbekannter Passagen von antiken
Klassikern wie dem Gilgamesh-Epos
veröffentlicht KI einsetzen um
Datenmassen zu analysieren auch anderswo
dürfte das immer mehr Bedeutung bekommen
ein Bereich ist die Medizin dort haben
wir auch riesen Datenmengen zum Beispiel
war ich der Radiologie wo Strukturen
erkannt werden können und darauf dann
basieren Diagnosen erstellen werden
können tausende Jahre alte Gedanken
entschlüsseln diesen Ziel bringt die
künstliche Intelligenz die Forschung in
jedem Fall ein ganzes Stück näher
beim Sport beginnen wir mit Skispringen
und das war heute ja nicht ganz
ungefährlich in Willingen der Wind hat
manche ganz schön extrem weit nach unten
geblasen aber zum Glück ohne schlimme
Folgen trotz der erschwerten
Wetterbedingungen hat das deutsche
mixt-team Platz 3 erreicht beim
Skisprung Weltcup Clara Sieger nach nur
einem Durchgang das norwegische Quartett
vor Österreich
das deutsche mix-team strahlte über den
zweiten Welt kaputt ist Platz dieser
Saison mit stürmischen Böden war dieses
Skifliegen auf der Mühlenkopfschanze
aber durchaus gefährlich Selina Freitag
sprang als erster auf 132 Meter Karl
Geiger zuletzt noch vom schwach gelang
der weiteste Sprung im deutschen Team
auf 140m das freute auch Katharina
Althaus die mixteen Weltmeisterin
Andreas Wellinger der Skisprung
Olympiasieger lieferte 135 einhalb Meter
hatte allerdings nur noch Augen für den
Slowenien Timmy Seitz der wurde von
einer Höhe auf
161,5 m getragen achteinhalb Meter
weiter als Schanzenrekord und war
ziemlich spektakulär gestürzt darum kein
neuer Rekord Salz blieb zum Glück
unverletzt
ein Interview mit Manuel Neuer in der
Süddeutschen Zeitung sorgt für Zündstoff
die Entlassung seines Torwarttrainers
Tony tapallovic bei Bayern München Mitte
Januar sei das krasseste was er in
seiner Karriere erlebt habe sagte
derzeit verletzte nationalker der
paulowitsch war auf Betreiben von
Trainer nagelsmann freigestellt worden
zur Halbzeit der zweierbob-wm in St
Moritz liegen drei deutsche Teams auf
Medaillenrängen die besten Piloten Lisa
buckwitz und Anschieberin Kira
Lipperheide
überraschen den Führungen dieser
buckwitz die frühere Anschieberin von
Maria Maja Janka mit ihrer Anschieberin
Kira Lipperheide ihnen gelingen gleich
zwei stark Bestzeiten und so eine
Führung von 500 Sekunden ich bin
natürlich mega happy ich hätte dich
jetzt nicht gedacht dass ich jetzt auf
eins liege nach dem ersten Tag
hauchi mit Partnerin Leonie Fiebig
den Start im zweiten Lauf komplett
vermasselt hat zweier Bob
Olympiasiegerin Laura Nolte doch sie
kann ihren Fehler wieder gut machen Zeit
aufholen und sich noch auf Platz drei
schieben im Training war sie noch schwer
gestürzt morgen also drei Chancen auf
Gold im Zweierbob im Jubiläumsjahr 125
Jahre Bob in St Moritz
auf der Natur waren immer toll danke
schön jetzt noch ein Bild dass sie
bestimmt kennen aber vielleicht nicht
gleich erkennen das Mädchen mit dem
Perlenohrring von Jan Vermeer nicht
gemalt sondern aus 6000 Minifiguren
kreiert natürlich in den Niederlanden
schönes Hobby eigentlich
morgen gibt es noch Schnee in den Alpen
sonst beruhigt sich das Wetter mehr dazu
gleich von Christa Orden das heute
journal können Sie an diesem Abend um 22
Uhr sehen mit Anne Gellinek auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend ja mit leichtem
Zwischenhocheinfluss beruhigt sich das
Wetter morgen etwas das gilt aber nicht
für die Alpen ab heute Abend stauen sich
da wieder Schicht Schneefälle wir sehen
das hier in rosa und bis morgen
Nachmittag kommen 10 bis 30 für Einzel
50 cm Neuschnee vom Himmel auch im
Erzgebirge sind fünf bis zehn vereinzel
20 cm möglich Vorsicht auch hier vor
Schneeverwehungen denn anfangs gibt es
in der Nacht im Osten und im Süden noch
stürmische Höhen aber dann lässt der
Wind so langsam nach dazu setzt sich im
Osten schon langsam die kühlere Luft
durch
-1-2 Grad es kann glatt werden auf den
Straßen im Westen bleibt es milder mit
zwei Grad morgen gibt es eine ähnliche
Temperaturverteilung 1 bis 5 Grad im
Osten 5 bis 9 Grad im Westen dazu ist
das meist trocken wechseln bis stark
bewölkt die Schneeschauer im Erzgebirge
und der Dauer Schneefall an den Alpen
lassen am Nachmittag nach dazu gibt es
im Nordosten und Südosten sogar häufiger
mal die Sonne am Sonntag frisch der Wind
allerdings wieder auf und neuer Schnee
und Regen schwenken über uns hinweg
abends erreichen die erneut die Alpen ab
Montag setzt sich von Osten dann aber
die Kaltluft durch es wird nachts
frostiger tagsüber aber sonniger tschüss